you know i hate to say
i told you so you know how much i hate
to say that but one of the things that
i've told you on this show is that the
difference between a conspiracy theory
and the truth is about six to nine
months well
nine months ago the fda approved the
first booster shots for the covid
vaccine
almost exactly nine months ago at the
time
i made fun of the booster shots because
i knew that they were not going to do
what the libs told us they were going to
do
i knew that because the vaccines
themselves the the first shots didn't do
what the libs told us that they would do
namely to prevent infection and
transmission of the virus if the
vaccines had done
what they were supposed to do we
wouldn't have needed the boosters
when i doubted the vaccines
i was called a conspiracy theorist then
almost exactly nine months after the
vaccines came out we got the boosters
and when i doubted the boosters i was
called you guessed it a conspiracy
theorist and now
nine months later
we get this headline
this headline why boosted americans
seem to be getting more covid19
infections this is from cbs news they
say that as covid19 cases began to
accelerate the spring federal data
suggests
the rate of breakthrough coveted
infections there's always breakthrough
everyone's getting it but it's all it's
breakthrough the rate of breakthrough
coveted infections in april was worse
in boosted americans compared to
unboosted americans
that's really strange and they make a
point to say
the rates of death and hospitalization
remain the lowest among the boosted okay
but the cases they're more prominent
among the boosted than the unboosted
the new data do not mean booster shots
are somehow increasing the risk no no no
ongoing studies continue to provide
strong evidence of additional protection
blah blah blah blah
instead
the shift underscores the growing
complexity of measuring vaccine
effectiveness at this stage of the
pandemic it's the growing when they get
everything wrong that's just evidence of
the growing complex it's so complex you
probably wouldn't understand it except
you did understand it and i understood
it wasn't complex to us nine months ago
isn't complex to us now as simple as
this they were wrong about everything
that's it it's actually pretty simple if
you realize they're wrong about
everything
if you still trust
our pretentious ruling class
i can't help you i can't i'm sorry i
can't help you
it is not just that that kovid has
proven their idiocy
these are people
who believe who say with their very own
voices that babies are not babies these
are people
in their genius lab coats with their
stethoscopes who say that men are
actually women secretly somewhere deep
down these are people who tell you not
to let monkey pox interrupt your gay
orgies you're hearing this from public
health officials at fancy places these
are some of the most radical
least logical people on the face of the
earth and if you want a good rule of
thumb to protect yourself and the public
health
whatever these people tell you to do you
are probably better off doing the
opposite i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from jimmy
bloomfield who says
wow whole new meaning to the phrase the
few
the proud
the marines yes i guess that
that uh super duper gay tweeting that
was going on from the marines
and the air force interestingly not the
navy or the army or the coast guard but
two branches of the military were really
talking about how important
pride month celebrations are to going
out and killing the enemy or whatever
that really does give a new meaning to
that phrase maybe it was there all along
it was there in the tagline we just
couldn't
see it
now when you see something and you want
to talk to
me about it when you want to talk to
your friends about it when you talk want
to talk to your loved ones
you got to check out puretalk right now
go to puretalk.com enter promo code
noles podcast i freaking love these guys
i know that people have a reticence to
switch their cell phone because it's
such a hassle to open up a cell phone
line that people just stay stuck with it
for the rest of their lives even though
the prices go up all the time and the
even though the cell phone companies are
selling wokeness but that's how they get
you they get you stuck in a rut do not
do it i love puretalk they've got the
absolute best coolest newest phones i
got my beautiful
apple iphone 13 from puretalk just the
other day they got all sorts of cool
colors their service is top-notch
whether you are on att or verizon or
t-mobile or whatever you are going to
get the exact comparable service really
really top stuff the pure talk ceo is a
u.s veteran you've got america's most
reliable 5g network unlimited talk
unlimited text 6 gigs of data you'll get
it for 30 a month watch the catch there
isn't a catch it's just phenomenal go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that's
right for you puretalk.com enter promo
code knowles podcast to save 50 off your
first month that is promo code noles
podcast canon wles
p-o-d-c-a-s-t all one word at
puretalk.com puretalk is simply smarter
wireless they were wrong about
everything with kovid
i really want to drive that point home
because at the time
two years ago more than two years ago
now two and a half years ago almost
when kovid really started cropping up
a lot of conservatives went along with
it and i i understand it was a once in a
generation kind of political operation
and you had all the fancy people in the
lab coats and even a lot of elected
republicans went along with it and so
although some conservatives had a little
bit of trepidation about giving away all
of our political rights and upending our
whole way of life because of this
mysterious virus
people gave the public health
establishment the benefit of the doubt
some of us were a little more skeptical
some of us said you know
i don't know the
the measures that they're calling for
don't really seem to be backed up by the
data the the new measures like everyone
wearing the masks well just a week ago
the public health people were telling us
that the masks don't work that doesn't
hold on you're telling me standing six
feet away from someone that's really
going to protect us from that doesn't
seem very likely hold on the virus
mostly affects elderly people and people
with weak immune systems so why are we
locking little kids who are otherwise
all these questions right
they never had a good answer and the
establishment would change its answer
every day and as the as the whole thing
dragged on more and more people began to
understand oh this is a farce this is
preposterous the emperor has no clothes
so
the next stage of that was a couple of
months ago when kovid was killing
democrats in the polls all of a sudden
they started to take their foot off the
accelerator just a little bit
they realized this was going to really
hurt them in the midterms so they said
okay hey guys don't we're going to move
on now this is great biden beat covid
okay this is awesome but i said watch
out they're going to bring it back and
they're going to bring it back the way
you know they're going to bring it back
is because they're not getting rid of
the emergency
authorization the national emergency
authorization they're still fighting
tooth and nail to keep the vaccine
mandates in they're still fighting tooth
and nail to keep the mask mandates in so
they're they're they might be pulling
away from the the enforcement right now
but they're keeping all of the power
all of the potential power and that's
what we saw yesterday the covid
coordinator at the white house
not dr fauci he's some other guy because
fouchy was killing their poll numbers so
they put him into witness protection for
a while
this new guy the new co the new dr kovid
shows up to the white house he's asked a
very simple question which is okay we're
over two years into this thing can you
say definitively that the white house is
going to support opening the schools in
the fall for all the students
and the covid coordinator is not even
able to get his answer out
doctor do you believe all schools will
and must be open this coming fall
you have to go i unfortunately yes
i'm sorry
thank you sorry
sorry you got to go hold on and there
she is corrine jean-pierre the press
secretary walks up no no he can't
there's not enough time to answer that
really basic question that requires a
one-word answer
yes yes or no and obviously the answer
should be yes no no okay get out of here
you get out of here all right so
anyway what were we talking about yeah
okay moving on moving on nothing to see
here because the white house doesn't
want to commit to that
because
the potential for the covid lockdowns
gives
gives the ruling class a lot of power
it gave them the power most notably in
2020 to change all of the election rules
you would not you would not have gotten
the widespread mail-in ballots the huge
expansion of election day to election
season
the uh not not even the just the mail-in
ballots but the
the mail the widespread mailing of the
ballots to the voters without the voters
requesting them themselves in some cases
in direct violation of state laws in the
state constitution
you wouldn't have had any of that
without covid
and specifically without the lockdowns
that allowed the public health officials
and the politicians but i repeat myself
to to change the way that we all operate
in society so they're keeping that in
their in their quiver right now and as
the polls continue to get worse for
democrats they'll probably need to
they'll probably need to go back to that
old playbook
it's both
both ignorant and cynical
it's somehow both ignorant and cynical
right the the ruling class doesn't know
what it's talking about the ruling class
has gotten pretty much everything wrong
about kovid if they were being sincere
and above board but also they don't care
they don't care about the truth that's
what cynicism is is when you just you
don't care about the truth when jesus
says to pontius pilate i am the truth
and pontius pilate shrugs his shoulders
and says what is truth that's cynicism
and that's what you get from
the white house certainly but also from
the public health establishment when dr
fauci says
don't wear the masks the masks don't
work and then two seconds later he says
wear the masks you have to wear the
masks the masks are very effective
and
that there that could just be
incompetence there that could just be
ignorance
but he shows you later on it's cynicism
because he says yeah look when i told
you not to wear the masks i wanted to
save the masks for all my friends in
public health so i lied and told you
that i misrepresented my opinion on the
masks to you so that you wouldn't go buy
them but then when i saw there were
enough of my friends then i told you to
go buy them and i changed my opinion
that's cynicism that's where you frankly
can't even tell the difference between
truth and lies all that matters to you
is the implementation of your agenda all
that matters to you is the exercise of
your will that's what you're getting
from the white house right now
that's what you're getting from the
political establishment and it's not
just on kovit kovid is the
least usual the most unusual and most
annoying
version of this
but you're seeing it on every other
issue especially now
the issue that the democrats are really
driving home which is guns
the democrats have focused on the mass
shooting in texas
as an opportunity to drive home their
agenda about guns
even though the gun agenda that they're
driving would not have stopped that
shooting or any other big shooting in
recent years there's no evidence
whatsoever even the washington post fact
checkers admit
that
at least for the earlier shootings i
don't think there's been a fact check on
this one but for the earlier mass
shootings that we've seen in recent
years none of these gun control
proposals would have changed anything
but the democrats don't care because
what they're after is not to prevent
these kinds of particular incidents they
don't really care much about these
incidents at all they're just trying to
pursue the same old agenda that they've
had for decades now when you want to
protect yourself not just your community
not just your way of life but your home
you've got to check out ring right now
go to ring.com
knowles it's the summer summer is busy
people travel i'm traveling i'm always
on the road sometimes i'm there with
sweet little elise and the baby
sometimes they stay home i go on the
road you want to be able to protect your
home wherever you are whether you're in
the home whether you're outside the home
you can do that with a ring you know you
can do that with the ring video doorbell
you know that you can see and speak to
whoever is at your doorstep no matter
where you are on earth you know you can
do that with ring alarm protect your
home from freeze fire flood from the bad
guys keep an eye on your windows on your
doors but have you gone pro
have you gotten the ring alarm pro yet
you've got to go pro cnut calls ring
alarm pro a giant leap for home security
because
ring alarm pro allows you to protect
your physical home and
your virtual home your digital home your
data you live so much of your life
online make sure you protect your data
with a wi-fi protection you get from
ring and the physical protection you get
from ring it's just a phenomenal service
the cost is extremely low go to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com
knowles
ohio just voted to approve a bill to arm
teachers
this is going to be a controversial bill
because the democrats hate
guns
and the democrats want to get rid of
guns and a bill to arm teachers is going
to encourage people to have more guns if
any either it'll
keep the gun the gun number about the
same or it will increase the number of
guns out there and so the democrats are
very upset about this
but this is a very good law the ohio
republican governor mike dewine is
expected to sign this bill
that the gop legislature
the gop led legislature passed this is a
good bill
just
here's how you know it's a good bill
for a moment
take away every preconceived
desire that you've got in politics all
the rules you want everything you want
to change just take that away and just
focus for one second on a school you've
got a school
two schools you got one school
where the teachers and the staff are
permitted to carry guns
and you don't know which teachers are
exercising that right and which teachers
are not but you know that there are
going to be guns in this school
then you got a school that's a gun free
zone where you know no guns are allowed
anywhere around that school maybe a
resource officer is allowed to carry one
maybe
which school do you think is more likely
to be shot up by a lunatic
which one
the one where you don't know
if you bust into that school with a gun
if you're going to be taken out by that
guy or that guy or that guy or all of
them at once
or the school where everyone's a sitting
duck obviously it's the former
regardless of what you think about guns
second step are school shootings being
carried out by teachers with their guns
or school shootings being carried out by
aids with their guns
no the school shootings are always
carried out by crazy weirdo
students many of whom show a lot of
warning signs that are completely
ignored
because often of political correctness
and because of neglect and because of
inefficiency and sometimes corruption at
the schools
but what we know for sure that's a
separate issue what we know for sure is
the school shootings are not being
carried out by teachers with their guns
or aids with their guns
so it's not going to increase the risk
to students
and it is going to decrease the risk if
you want to reduce the likelihood of
school shootings
there is no question
arm arming or allowing teachers to arm
themselves and aids to arm themselves
would accomplish that there's no i don't
i don't see how you could argue
otherwise the only thing you could argue
is well we don't want more guns out
there well guns are just bad generally
and so we want fewer guns not more guns
so no more guns
but that's a totally sep now you're just
talking about guns
in a way that is almost entirely
unrelated to school shootings
so on this issue the libs have to pick
they've got a very stark choice before
them
protect kids
or pursue their mostly unrelated gun
control agenda
they're mutually exclusive
and the libs are totally picking the
ladder uniformly almost i think without
exception
and the republicans are choosing the
former
you might you might say well it's just
because republicans love guns yeah
republicans do love guns and they do a
lot of republicans do at least yeah it's
true it's just because republicans love
their second amendment right yup you're
damn right we do uh-huh
but that again that's sort of beside the
point here i'm not talking in the
abstract i'm not talking about some
grand ideology i'm just talking about
the practical question what is more
likely to protect kids at schools
the shooter goes in and he doesn't know
which teachers and aides have guns or
shooter goes in sitting ducks he knows
it's a gun-free zone it's obviously the
former we i know we don't we don't get
the libs to admit basic facts these days
men are not women babies or babies but
but come on if we're being serious we're
being sincere we're having a good faith
debate obviously
that policy would reduce the likelihood
of a mass shooting in a school and the
libs don't care because they're pursuing
their own agenda furthermore libs in
california are now making it harder to
identify threats
people who could cause violence at
schools earlier on there's the
california senate which just passed a
bill no longer requiring teachers to
report incidents to the police
this is senate bill 1273
states that current law holds that a
person quote who willfully disturbs any
public school or any public school
meeting is guilty of a misdemeanor and
shall be punished by a fine if not more
than five hundred dollars uh this bill
would make it so that enrolled students
would no longer be held liable for such
an offense
so the students would
the school would not report these
incidents to authorities
now you might say look if a student
is messing around at school and i don't
know he does something stupid he pulls a
prank he disrupts a class the class
clown does the class clown need to be
reported to the police every time he
pulls a prank no
i don't think so
but what if students are
causing
real disruptions what if students are
exhibiting really troubling behavior
do you think that the schools should
report that to authorities well
if your
goal is to reduce the likelihood of
violence at schools
there's no question here
of course the schools should report the
behavior
but if you are pursuing a different
agenda if you are pursuing the agenda of
abolish the police the the agenda of
we've got an over over incarceration
problem the agenda of we shouldn't
punish people for doing bad things
especially if they're of a protected
race or a protected class or protected
geographic area that would be
inequitable and terrible and racist and
bigoted and whatever pc nonsense they
want to spend if you're pursuing that
agenda then you say yeah don't just
brush it under the rug
when a a transgender bathroom comes at
the heart of of a horrible rape that
occurs in a school loudoun county
virginia when a guy wearing a dress goes
in and rapes a girl in the girl's
bathroom
and the guy's allowed into the girls
bathroom because of these insane
transgender policies well uh if you want
to protect kids obviously you don't let
boys in the girls room if you want to
pursue your radical abstract sexual
agenda then you have to let boys into
the girls room and so what do you do if
it's a former case you fix the problem
if it's the latter case you transfer the
boy to another school and you sweep it
under the rug what did the libs do in
loudoun county what are the libs doing
in california what are the libs doing
all over it has nothing to do with
protecting kids it has everything to do
with
with pursuing their own unrelated agenda
when the two come into conflict they
always pick
the latter
you want to talk about incidents in
schools
there there's a teacher who's of course
of course taken to tiktok
thank goodness for tick-tock tick-tock
is the greatest honey pot that
conservatives ever invented i'm starting
to think xi jinping is on our side
because tick-tock just attracts these
lunatics and predators to go on the
platform and confess they're extremely
creepy and in some cases criminal
behavior
and then then there's a great twitter
account called libs of tick tock that
takes that from tick tock where
adult conservatives generally are not to
twitter where we are and posts it for us
so libs of tick tock just found this
lady she's complaining
that her second grade students
did not understand the phrase non-binary
gender
so today in queer teacher things um one
of my students asked about my
roommate um because i know i have a
roommate and
i told them their name and they asked my
roommate was a boy or girl and i said
neither
and they were like no miss brown
are they a boy or a girl i was like my
friend they're neither they were like
well do they have a boy name or a girl
name and i said neither and they said
well do they wear boy clothes or girl
clothes and i said well what are boy
clothes and girl clothes and they go you
know
and i said no my friend i don't know
what our boy closing girl clothes and
they said well what kind of clothes do
they wear and i said
well they normally wear jeans and a
t-shirt and they said well what color is
the t-shirt and i said
all colors and they said well that
doesn't make any sense and i said it
doesn't have to make sense and then they
walked away because they got mad at me
out of the mouth of babes such wisdom
out of the mouth of babes
and credit to this teacher at least well
i don't want to give the devil as do
here but i will give the devil her due
in that at the end she acknowledges that
it doesn't make sense
the kids say this doesn't make sense and
she says yeah yeah it doesn't have to
make sense
she's she's calling her second grade
students my friend my friend like she's
a a middle easterner at a bazaar trying
to sell you cheap goods my friend my
friend i am selling you non-binary my
friend my friend for you good good price
best price for you my friend on
transgender pangender non-binary my
friend
then the students say well hold on
that your roommate their
gender it their t-shirt their color it
doesn't it doesn't have to make sense
and she's right she's right
society doesn't have to make sense
we can live in a
chaotic
anarchistic
cacophonous
mayhem of a society we can and
increasingly that is what we are doing
but if you want education to be
education if you want to make sense of
your freedom if you want to cultivate
your rational will if you want to get
along and flourish
that does have to make sense we do need
sense we do need logic and reason when
the libs have to choose between
educating the children that they seem to
care so much about
educating them giving them a good
education teaching them to make sense of
their freedom and advancing their insane
political sexual cultural ideology which
are they going to pick
100 times out of 100 it is going to be
the latter
the sexual indoctrination of children
starts at a very young age
and this is true by the way
in all cultures and in all societies
this is the one point that the libs get
right actually when the libs say that we
need to teach
sex to kindergarteners
they're they're right in the sense that
when you read a storybook when a normal
kindergarten teacher in a normal
kindergarten class in a normal society
something we haven't had in a long time
when that teacher reads a book a board
book about mama bear and papa bear and
baby bear to the class
that is a kind of sexual instruction
because what it's saying is
that family looks a certain way and that
marriage looks a certain way and that
men and women relate to one another in a
certain way
and when men and women come together in
this thing called marriage through some
kind of process you get little baby bear
and and so that is a kind of sexual
teaching
what the libs want is extremely creepy
perverse pornographic disordered sexual
teaching so obviously that's very bad
but but there's always
they are right that there is always a
kind of sexual instruction going on
because men and women are different
we're exposed to them from the very
beginning and
we ask
mommy what what why are you and daddy
married well when a man and a woman love
each other very much they come together
and they get married and they start a
family oh okay mommy all right and then
when the little kid's really little is
mommy where do babies come from well you
came from mommy's belly then the kid
gets older and they get a little bit
more into detail but that that does
start
from an early age and so i have
i have a great deal of sympathy
for parents who are who are falling prey
to the left's
perversions here there's a couple
that uh just again took to tick-tock
took took to the honeypot
to explain
how their daughter
knew that she was a boy
starting around age two
you ready
on the 6th of march we welcomed our
beautiful twins into the world a boy
called arlo and a girl called emerald
the first one they said was this is a
girl i genuinely remember your face just
like lighting up like this is amazing
and then the next one is on this is a
boy jackpot you know one of each this is
the perfect combination here
look at that
so now they're four years old and
they identify as two boys
the first time that i realized stormy
wanted to identify as male was about
roughly two and a half
but
it's not really he said i want to be a
boy he said i am a boy
and that is the difference
my name is stormy and i'm four years old
i feel like a boy and i want to be a boy
sometimes people call me girl
do they how does that make you feel sad
when you watch this
you get very angry if you're a normal
person you can't help but get angry you
say this poor kid the kid can barely
speak he's a four-year-old he says
i'm a boy now or i said he because it's
so confusing that does she she says
i'm a boy and i know and so you're
telling me at two and a half
the baby knew that she was a boy no this
owes to the
confusion of the parents and the
confusion of this culture
when i was a four-year-old i said i was
batman i really did i went for like two
weeks i put on a cape and i demanded
that everyone call me batman i know that
conservatives use this as a kind of
flippant example that i actually did
that when i was four when i was the age
that that little girl is now
and my mother tolerated my wearing the
cape a little bit but she never she
never
embraced my identity entirely as a
billionaire who fights crime if only she
had i would have loved to be treated
like a billionaire as a little kid but
it would not have been good for my
flourishing because it wasn't true
wasn't
it wasn't in accord with reality even
still as angry as one gets at these
parents
i have a great deal of sympathy because
these parents in particular
admitted they said man this seems
so crazy it seems so so crazy but i just
i just want to do what's best for my kid
i can't remember the exact moment it
switched over but there was that point
where i thought you know what this isn't
just this isn't just a phase this is not
a little girl we're looking at it's a
little boy
he started being unhappy with being
dressed as a girl so he started being
unhappy wearing dresses hair clips were
a big no-no didn't like hair clips
didn't like the pigtails he was
genuinely
upset at being dressed as a girl before
i had children and certainly before the
last couple of years this whole thing
that i'm saying i would have thought it
was ridiculous honestly i would i would
have i would have watched me
and said no you you're crazy you're
making it up you're abusing a child
we constantly say are you a boy today or
do you feel like you might because i
don't want him to feel like he's took
himself down a route that he can't turn
back
i'm really glad that this couple
included this explanation it
in a way it redeems them and the abuse
that they are carrying on against their
daughter
because i bet there are a lot of parents
who feel this way
who say
well you know my my child is has a
little bit of a fantasy but but the
culture tells me that if i don't affirm
the fantasy then i'm going to make my
kid commit suicide that's what they tell
you
they say if you do not affirm this
child's fantasy
the kid's going to kill him or herself
and it's going to be your fault and any
parent will do anything to protect their
kid but the parents obviously have some
trepidation here and they say but i i
don't want put the power my daughter
down a path you know feel like she's
going down a path where she can't get
back but necessarily she will be
especially when kids are really really
little their brains are like sponges
they're so malleable
the more they behave in a certain way
the more they are going to behave in a
certain way that's true of all of us
that's just what habit is but especially
when you're a kid you form habits much
more easily and they can stick a lot
longer that's why it's so much easier to
learn a foreign language when you're a
little kid than when you're older and
and so the longer that they do this and
then obviously if they end up using
puberty blockers or or cross-sex
hormones or any of the poison that these
psychos in big pharma and in our the
cultural left are forcing on little kids
then they then they're on a path where
it's virtually impossible to get back
i just would encourage parents who are
in this position
do not allow yourself to fall prey to
the
insane psychotic false emotional
blackmail do not allow yourself to to uh
distrust your gut instinct your gut
instinct is right our
even our medical establishment certainly
the cultural establishment but even our
medical establishment is completely
without credibility they ha they are the
emperor without clothes they've proven
that i think definitively over the last
two years and and now it's no longer
about making you wear some stupid cloth
mask now it's about permanently
destroying your little child's body do
not believe them trust your gut
on this exact issue daily wire has got a
new documentary out that you have got to
see
you know what i'm talking about i'm
talking about what is a woman matt
walsh's documentary that is
magnificent here's what people are
saying about it ali stuckey says it's
compelling funny terrifying but hopeful
tim poole says it's extremely well done
and a must watch megan kelly says the
film has a very serious message one
you're going to want to hear molly
hemingway the great molly hemingway says
it's funny and thought-provoking lauren
southern says it's a show-and-tell of
crazy and steve dace from the blaze says
it's a weapon of mass destruction in the
culture war but who cares what any of
them say i'm telling you it's phenomenal
it's a phenomenal film
matt does
i
i i can't overstate what a great job he
does these interviews are incredible the
guy flew to africa to interview a tribe
to ask them about
transgenderism and non-binary it's
really good and it doesn't just own the
libs it owns the libs with a purpose
and it's very serious you're going to
laugh you're going to want to throw a
remote at your tv it's it's really
incredible so right now head on over to
what is a woman.com
uh the movie is only for members so
you've got to go to what is a woman.com
subscribe you get 25 off your membership
we need your we need your memberships we
need your subscriptions uh that's how we
can make more more movies also speaking
of movies that came out on a totally
different side of the cultural front
right now but i i've been meaning to
mention it all week and i just have
not had the time to
i also am in a movie that just came out
it's called mass of the ages for those
of you who are on the papist side of the
audience into a little potpourri now and
again and even for the non-catholics who
just want to see how our crazy culture
got to where it is and one of the
biggest least talked about uh
aspects of that and and changes that
took place it's about the old latin mass
and how how it all transformed after the
second vatican council uh it's right now
it's on youtube i believe it's for free
it's called mass of the ages part two uh
so go check that out too
we have come to my absolute favorite
time of the week when i get to hear from
you in the mail bag and i get to
literally hear from you now we're still
reading the typed in mailbag questions
but thanks to puretalk we now have the
voicemail bag i love puretalk i have my
puretalk phone
i've i've got it all set up i absolutely
love it they've got the best latest
newest coolest iphones whatever phone
you want the service cannot be beat it
is exactly as good as all the other top
tier really best services you can get
unlimited text unlimited talk yet six
gigs of data it's just a phenomenal
service you will save so much money on
your plan go to puretalk.com enter promo
code knowles podcast right now on top of
the amazing savings you'll save 50
off your first month
people are always skeptical about
switching phones that's how the that's
how the big awful phone companies just
get you stuck in a rut so i i promise
you right now go to puretalk.com
use that code knowles podcast
you're going to love pure talk only
subscribers can submit voicemail bags so
if you're not a member head on over to
dailywire.com slash knowles or use promo
code nulls for 10 off let's get to the
first voicemail bag
hey michael i just wanted to ask do you
think that roe v wade is going to be
rightfully overturned or that the work
will undermine a democracy thanks
i think it will i i would bet money
right now that roe v wade will be
overruled
the at least according to that leaked
opinion
uh the court will vote 6-3 to uphold the
pro-life law in mississippi and then the
court will vote 5-4 to overrule roe v
wade and planned parenthood be casey
who knows it's it's kind of a fool's
errand to try to guess what the court is
going to do
but all the gossip that i've heard out
of washington dc is that the court is
sticking by their guns the conservatives
sort of have to because if the
conservatives
switch their opinions because of the
angry mobs that the left sent to their
homes then it totally destroys the
credibility of the court and of the
decision by the way
and all the future controversial
opinions
we'll just see more mob violence outside
of houses so i sort of think that they
have to do it which is very good news
for us and very good news for babies
hey michael i hope you're doing well
my name is laura and i work and go to
school here in nashville
so hey neighbor
but my question for you is what advice
do you have for people who work in an
environment that is hostile to the
conservative christian worldview
for context
i work at starbucks
i'm sure you are well aware that most
people there do not like christians or
conservatives
i have to be cautious with what i say
around them and i have to be very
careful about how i refer to my
transgender co-workers
that being said as a christian
i am commanded to share the gospel with
them
and as time has progressed
i have come to care about them
i could see how much pain they have in
their lives
and i want nothing more than for them to
come to know christ as their savior
how can i speak the truth to them
without explicitly mentioning religion
or politics
thanks god bless you
consider it an opportunity this is such
a great question
consider it an opportunity
when
saint paul
and other disciples go into corinth
and the corinthians are doing all sorts
of
things that they shouldn't be doing and
are in i'm sure a lot of pain
you go in and you might not be met with
the warmest welcome but nevertheless you
have the opportunity to improve their
lives to improve the world
to save their souls to spread the gospel
isn't that great to lead them on a path
to god when saint thomas
takes a boat out he shipwrecks on
socotra off the coast of somalia and
yemen and then goes on to india and
spreads the gospel there and then
eventually gets gets killed and possibly
eaten i think
ultimately you know you could look at
that and say gosh that sounds so
terribly unpleasant saint paul getting
beaten and knocked over the head and
imprisoned and ultimately you know they
end his life
but
what a great opportunity to be
to spread the gospel we're all going to
have suffering we're all going to die
someday no one here gets out alive but
but
how can you take
suffering and turn it for the good and
make it sanctifying and make it
productive that's a great way to do it
it also helps
i love starbucks
starbucks is a woke corporation
it's true that i think a few years ago
they said that if if employees wanted to
donate to charities they would match
some of the charitable donations
including to planned parenthood that was
very annoying that's awful
it's true that
starbucks signals all sorts of woke
stuff but first of all so does pretty
much every other company in america so
if you're if you're going to say all
right i'm in the middle of new york and
i want to get a cup of coffee but i'm
not going to go into that store well
then you can't go in anywhere basically
because they're all of these
corporations and then you go into
starbucks and i've had this experience
it's
exactly what you're describing where
most people at starbucks are kind of lib
but just because i have something of a
public platform i'll go in and and very
often someone at starbucks one of the
employees will come up and say
hey
hey man i'm i'm on your side i'm out you
know i like the show but these guys
around me they hate it and i don't know
how to talk to them and you know there
is it's like you got to do a secret
handshake like you kick your leg
underneath a bathroom stall or something
you're
we used to say friend of abe out in
hollywood
it was the secret
message that you were a conservative
just like in the old days gay guys would
say they were a friend of dorothy
because people it was oppressive you
know
for gay people it was you had to hide
your your true identity so
obviously that exists at starbucks but
if you look at these people as you say
as being just in pain being confused
when you see someone with lots of crazy
hair and lots of mutilations and kind of
scowling and angry all the time that
person
probably doesn't have their life in
great order
you look at the conservatives generally
but pretty happy and stable you look at
the libs not screaming and shrieking
just look at any pro-abortion or
pro-life rally which side looks more
normal so you have an opportunity to
spread some of that peace that you feel
uh take that opportunity might it might
be unpleasant for you
but embrace that if you're saying how do
i avoid the unpleasantness you're not
going to so just embrace it and and kiss
it up to god
next question hi michael thank you for
all you do for speaking truth with
compassion and care and for evangelizing
the christian faith my question for you
is as a practicing catholic who might
who i'm sure has many friends who are
gay how do you broach the topic of their
dating lives if they bring it to you
um as a practicing catholic myself who
has many dear friends who are gay and
who also know my position
on
on the proper order of marriage
i'm never quite sure how to
broach conversations in which they bring
up their dating lives and struggles and
frustrations
so what advice would you have to respond
with love and care while staying true to
the catholic teaching on marriage
thank you
i usually just punch them you know i
really i just try to harm them and i i
you know hit him over the head no no i
don't do that you're right i do have
many gay friends uh i am from new york i
lived in los angeles i went to one of
the gayest colleges ever in the history
of higher education so it's through many
many disproportionate number of my
friends over the course of my life uh
have been gay guys
uh so so what does that mean for someone
who
holds to catholic teachings
on marriage and human sexuality and
everything
well it means that
i don't show my gay friends the
disrespect of pandering to them
this is something i also it's a little
self-selecting because my gay friends
tend to be
[Music]
quite traditional i know that seems like
a contradiction in terms but they get it
they're not in denial they're not out
there with crazy colored hair screaming
you know wearing
leather vests at a pride parade jiggling
for kids you know down fifth avenue or
something that's not it's not we're just
talking about guys who have uh unusual
sexual attractions and so
i have gay friends who say i'm gonna i'm
gonna be
i'm just gonna repress my sexuality and
i'm just not going to indulge in that
and i'm going to be celibate and i'm
going to remain chaste i've got some gay
friends who don't do that who say i want
to be in a monogamous relationship with
another man
i've got some gay friends who don't who
are who are big libs and who
you know i hope they don't get the
monkey pox but they definitely continue
to live more colorful lives in that
regard
they know what i think i'm not gonna
hide it from them if they're willing to
still be friends with me
even though i'm a catholic then i'm
obviously willing to still be friends
with with anybody who is going to be
respectful of that and thoughtful but i
think the reason that i described to you
those
those different different shades of gay
is because one the gay community lgbt is
not uniform okay you know the pride
parade wants to pretend that everyone is
out there you know like rupaul trying to
groom little kids and that that's not
the case people are working through
their their
unusual desires they're they're working
through their struggles and things that
they bear in in different ways and so
what you can do what i like to do is
i i try to
model behavior that i think is conducive
to human flourishing and virtue and i
like all people sin and fall and fail
that's why i call myself a practicing
catholic because i'm going to keep on
practicing until i get it right but you
try to model that behavior and and
people will look around and say huh
maybe
maybe i i want to stop doing this one
thing and start doing this one thing ah
the way that that guy is behaving maybe
that seems more maybe it seems like more
like he's got things together okay i'll
try that
and that's that's what we do forget
about the gay issue i mean that's just
what we do in all aspects of our lives
and if if someone is going to cease to
be friends with you because of what you
believe or or your behavior or the way
that you live your life well i guess
they weren't great friends in the first
place all right one more voicemail back
hey michael it's me again nick um i'm
glad you have the voicemail back now i
feel like
much of the complexities of my
situations get lost in text
i don't like how sarcasm on twitter is
super great
you get it
anyways
as you know
sydney spelled with to ease from the
ayahuasca trip in tulum didn't pan out
which is fine however
i have been off my king energy again
because
i found out she hooked up with a friend
of mine
normally i wouldn't care bros over hoes
and all that but
this was a girlfriend of mine
and to make it worse it happened while
we were dating so
my question is
why does this feel different as much as
i hate to admit it when a girl cheats on
me with a dude i just feel like i need
to
wipe all social media and walk through a
car wash to wash away the shame
but when a girl cheats on me with
another girl
i just feel hurt
betrayed
she didn't invite me to the get-together
or at the very least like tell me about
it in great detail
why is this the case
thanks
love the show
i
thank you nick for your question
i
had this sense for a while that nick was
not a real person
or that nick was multiple people and
that some of the audience members just
decided to take on this character of
nick and now i'm hearing nick's voice
and i suppose i still wonder that but
i'm hearing nick's voice and nick does
sound exactly as i would have imagined
nick to sound like it's a good question
though it's actually it's actually
somewhere down down that rabbit hole
there is a good question
especially coming after the amber herd
trial
you know amber heard was married to
johnny depp and but previously i guess
she had been in this long-standing
relationship with a woman and she was
very confused about these things so one
nick no you should not be watching your
girlfriend cheat on you whether it's
with a man or with a woman
it's true there is a great shame and
humiliation in being cuckolded the woman
goes out and cheats on you with a man
but if the woman cheats on you with a
woman in a way i suppose you would feel
less shame
there's just so it's you'd probably be
more confused or a normal person would
be more confused than anything but it is
a red flag in that one
men and women
relate to sex in different ways i know
this is contradictory to the orthodoxy
of modern leftism but they do men have a
much more physical basic drive for sex
women have a more emotional and
longer-term drive for sex this is why
men are more interested in having
one-night stands at their worst and
women are just less interested in that
and more interested in in being you know
really clingy and getting a boyfriend
and
it's kind of that meme of the crazy
looking girlfriend you know calling you
all the time and that's just that's just
a difference between men and women and
so if a woman is displaying more of a
masculine approach to sex and lust and
then if a woman is confused even about
what she
wants out of a romantic partner and what
it just tells you she
she
is probably not on the same page as you
are and probably not marriage material
at least yet
so you can take that shame
nick and maybe use it to find other fish
in the sea
maybe settle down last question from
elijah
dear michael thoughts on dating in high
school this girl i've been close friends
with for some time now
and are both romantically interested in
each other
she thinks that we should start dating
now while i think we should wait until
we're older my reasoning for this were
only 14 you read that right and i've
always thought you should date in your
later teens than mary young
she shares the same beliefs and
political views as me which is a rarity
around here so i don't want to lose my
chance with her but i also don't want to
rush into something and ruin what i
think could be a very successful
relationship thank you nostradamus for
your thoughts and insights love the show
and everything else you do at dw
i would date the girl
i would date the girl my grandparents
met and sort of started dating around
14. sweet little elise and i well she
had a crush on me in eighth grade i had
a crush on her in ninth grade it finally
worked out we got started dating when
she was 15 i was 16. and uh we my
grandparents and sweet little lace and i
both split for college and then both got
insanely jealous and then got back
together and my grandparents have been
married something like 70 years and
sweet little elisa obviously you know
just that my soul mate the the you know
my
heart's deepest longing at least on this
earth and so i do it i think it's great
i think that high school sweethearts
make uh for for a great married pair i'm
not saying you should go out and do all
sorts of naughty things that
unmarried people should not be doing
but you can date go to the ice cream
parlor go catch a movie together i think
that's a perfectly wonderful thing to do
you're not going to
win the girl by
staying apart and thinking about this in
a really clinical way you i think you
should
cultivate those kind of feelings in a
way that is age-appropriate and
hopefully will lead to your longer-term
flourishing all right i'm michael nolsas
the michael knowles show see you next
week
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin